we recently asked members of the
BuzzFeed community to share with us
their worst poop horror stories these
are the frightening results sorry Eileen
writes one time when I was nine I was
having dinner with family and friends
when the bubble guts hit we've all been
there Eileen I'm trying to be cool but
the storm a-brewin was having none of
that
I puckered my butt and pushed my butt
into the ship in hopes of smothering it
but nope the pressure of me pushing my
butt down actually made the poop chute
out like putting a finger on a garden
hose it shot up my dress and hit me in
the back of the neck I think I actually
died a little bit girl ho that's a lot
of distance on that poop Holly writes a
guy invited me over after dinner to
watch a movie I love her this is going
we started cuddling when I began to feel
sick from the food I bolted to the
bathroom where I had explosive diarrhea
I thought that would make me feel better
but nope
vomit started coming out I whipped
around throwing up in the toilet when I
sat to regain myself I saw I'd pooped on
his floor while I'd been vomiting I went
to clean it but there was a single
square of toilet paper left know who I
scooped it with the empty roll smearing
the poop into his floor hit the roll in
the trash and left he never asked me out
again I have a lot of questions Tara
view 27 writes I was constipated at my
boyfriend's parents house we've all been
there so he gave me milk of magnesia we
were lying in bed when I realized I'd
taken too much before I could stand out
diarrhea leaked out of my butthole I
scurry to the bathroom and saw my white
thong drenched him what look like
chocolate but smelled like death I
wrapped it in toilet paper and shoved it
in the trash later that day we were
greeted by his dog who had a white
string hanging out of his mouth after a
struggle my boyfriend pulled the string
revealing my mangled bomb no boy crystal
writes when I was about three years old
I took my poop and smear it on my mom's
mouth saying here mommy
some chocolate for you she told me she
brushed her teeth and
her mouth like 20 times 3 years old
you're too old for that
Kalin W writes I really had to poop
while staying at my new booze place so I
did what any girl would do I pretended
to shower so I could do the deed in
peace but something was wrong with his
toilet and I couldn't hold it in so
suddenly I was [ __ ] in his shower he
kept asking through the door if I was
okay so I kept insisting I didn't feel
well and was letting the water run over
me but I was actually trying to shove
the poop down the shower drain oh he
wanted to do after I got out was cuddle
you can't you can't look anyone in the
eye for like 4 to 6 hours after you like
try to Swiss cheese and poop down drains
CW rod right I was on a first date on
Christmas Eve so when we left the
restaurant everywhere else was closed it
was a 40-minute drive back to my house
and I began to get a horrendous feeling
in my stomach I started scanning for
somewhere to poop and when we approached
a closed gas station I blurted pull over
she hit the brakes and I jumped out
praying the bathroom would at least be
open it wasn't and I felt the poop fill
up my underwear behind this gas station
in freezing weather I stripped down to
my bare poopy ass and wiped as much as I
could I threw my underwear in the
dumpster put my poop stain pants back on
and tried to walk calmly back to her she
drove me home in silence and though I
didn't ask her to come in she did anyway
I took a long shower and was surprised
to see her still there after I got out
we've been together for seven years